hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcasts striatal synaptic dysfunction
in Parkinson's and Huntington's diseases
I am Judy O'Rourke and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage it
ask questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
humanae button lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CD
button located in the bottom left-hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. James Sir Meyer dr. sir
Meyer is the Nathan Smith Davis
professor and chair of the department of
physiology at the Feinberg School of
Medicine at Northwestern University and
director of omarska udall research
center of research research excellence
for Parkinson's disease at Northwestern
University dr. Sir Myers research
program focuses on the ionic mechanisms
underlying neural activity in the basal
ganglia and their modulation by
activation of g-protein coupled
receptors particularly those for
dopamine he has pioneered the
application of modern patch-clamp and
single cell gene profiling approaches to
understanding basal ganglia physiology
offer
more than 100 peer-reviewed publications
in journals such as science nature
neuron nature neuroscience and the
Journal of Neuroscience please refer to
dr. Sir Meyers image in the top left
corner of your screen for more
information about him I will now turn it
over to dr. Sir Meyer for his
presentation thank you Judy and I want
to thank labret swing us the opportunity
to talk a little bit about our work
today I also want to start out with a
disclaimer other than the ones and this
CME slide and that is it I'm really only
going to talk about Parkinson's disease
today because of the time limitations of
this particular presentation okay so
what many of you know something about
the basal ganglia the striatum which is
the part of the basal ganglia that I'm
going to focus on which is shown in this
slide and in color is it's a part of the
basal ganglia that is involved in
controlling goal-directed behavior habit
and thought now the basal ganglia is
part of a complex set of interconnected
subcortical nuclei that are shown here
the key components of the basal ganglia
shown and labeled so one of the core
questions that we grapple with is coming
up with a clear understanding of what
destroy them is doing in the control of
movement and habit and one of the ways
of thinking about this is to kind of
think about the striatum as a trusted
advisor to the cerebral cortex now I'm
from Chicago and so it's easy for me to
think about Rahm Emanuel and and Barack
Obama serving these two sorts of roles
the final decisions about movement and
thought are made by the cerebral cortex
but the striatum can advise the cerebral
cortex on how to act in a particular
situation now being a you know
equal-opportunity employer here I want
to also give the Republicans an
opportunity and so you can also think
about this if you're Republican about
you know who's the cerebral cortex and
who's this right um in an advisory sort
of situation like this one okay but I
think this gives a is a fairly
reasonable metaphor for how we currently
think about the relative roles of the
stratum and cortex and habit and
movement control now this is another way
of thinking about it and looking at it
the basal ganglia circuits help again
the cortex sort through various actions
possible actions in a particular context
they process that information and pass
that information back through the rest
of the basal ganglia through the
thalamus back to the cortex which helps
it decide again with what particular
action to engage in at a particular time
in a particular context so one of the
things I'm not going to talk a great
deal about is is exactly how that
decision is made and how that
recommendation is passed on to the
thalamus from the basal ganglia it
involves an interaction of two pathways
direct and indirect pathways within the
striatum but the details of that are not
well understood we're still trying to
understand exactly how that those two
pathways interact what we do know is
that the principal decision-makers in
this scheme our straddle GABAergic spiny
projection errors and pictures of these
two cell types are shown here they look
fairly similar and in these sorts of
drawings and they're distinguished from
interneural and smaller inter neurons
which are shown at the bottom of this
panel now one of the key features of
spiny projection neurons is that they're
spining and the spines are places of
synaptic contact with Luna motor check
inputs that are carrying information
from the cerebral cortex as well as from
thalamus and so synapses are made on the
tips of these spines which can be shown
seen here let's see if I can highlight
with one of these tools I'm not sure
that I'm going to be able to do that I
could draw an arrow maybe this is a
spine head there's a synapse made from a
cortical or thalamic neuron made on
those spine heads and so this is this is
the way that spiny neurons integrate
information
it's one of their distinctive features
and it turns out that this is it this is
important because we think that it's
highly likely that information about
past outcomes is stored in the structure
of these spines okay all right now what
are the key neuromodulators involved in
Parkinson's disease as well as
Huntington's disease but most clearly in
Parkinson's disease is dopamine dopamine
plays a very important role in the basal
ganglia it helps us choose the right
action in a particular situation and
particularly an action that maximizes
our pleasure and minimizes our our pain
and I'll explain that in just a second
now dopamine acts on the striatum
through g-protein coupled receptors the
direct and indirect pathway neurons
which are shown in this diagram
Express different classes of dopamine
receptor there are five dopamine
receptors that are known to exist the
most common ones are d1 receptors which
are present in direct pathway neurons
I'm sure these are the direct pathway
neurons here and these it's called the
direct pathway because it directly
projects an axon to the interface nuclei
of the basal ganglia the contrast
indirect pathway neurons
- shown here these are indirect pathway
neurons here they respond to dopamine by
transducing those signals through d2
dopamine receptors which have a very
distinctive second messenger coupling
inside the cell and so it leads to
different cellular effects than in
direct pathway dopamine neurons okay so
that's key to understanding how how the
high dopamine shapes straddle activity
now in particular when dopamine acts on
direct pathway neurons what it does is
it increases their excitability and this
is shown here by looking at how cells
respond to inter somatic current
injection so the current injection
protocol is shown at the bottom here
this is the current injection protocol
shown here and then that leads to
increased spiking of the cell now when
we put on a d1 receptor agonist the
amount of spiking increases and direct
pathway neurons that is d1 receptor
signaling increases the excitability
responsiveness of direct pathway neurons
in contrast in d2 receptor expressing
neurons same interests senator current
injection leads to spikes being a vocht
in the cell body but now when we
activate a d2 receptor agonist as we
apply dopamine to these cells the number
of spikes it's evoke by that same
stimulus decreases that is the d2
receptor signaling decreases the
excitability of these indirect pathways
finally projection neurons so this leads
to sort of a dichotomous effect of
dopamine on direct and indirect pathway
notes and so what we can think about it
is in terms of this sort of diagram so
that when dopamine is elevated in
response to reward or some
environmentally salient event
that leads to increased excitability of
direct pathway neurons these neurons
promote I hear these direct pathway
neurons these promote activity as they
promote action and at the same time
indirect pathway neurons are being
inhibited by dopamine so these neurons
over here the the indirect pathway
neurons are being inhibited by dopamine
so these are the neurons which tend to
suppress or diminish activity so when
dopamine goes up you tend to go and the
pathway that's responsible for cessation
or suppression of activity is suppressed
now in contrast when dopamine levels
fall and they will fall in response to
punishment or negative environmental
events what happens is the exact exact
opposite that is that indirect pathway
neurons become disinhibited these
neurons become disinhibited leads to
elevated activity of this indirect
pathway circuitry and cessation of
activity and at the same time the g1
neurons direct pathway neurons are just
facilitated so their activity drops
because dopamine which tends to excite
them is fallen okay so this leads to
this bi-directional control of action
selection and movement alright so in
addition to controlling the immediate
excitability the short-term excitability
of direct and indirect pathway neurons
dopamine also controls the long-term
excitability of
these two pathways and it does that by
controlling synaptic plasticity that is
the strength of the synaptic connections
made by these neurons with both the
cerebral cortex and thalamus now the
chain this changing synaptic strength is
thought to be
one way in which movement the
consequences of movement are stored in
the stratum for future reference so that
that advisory role of the stratum can be
played out from moment to moment now we
know that there was the structural
substrates for this kind of synaptic
plasticity cortical glutamatergic
synapses form triads with spiny
projection neurons this is shown in an
electron micrograph to the right here in
the panel this is from Paul balam's work
we can make a cartoon out of this to
sort of understand exactly what this
spatial relationship is between all of
these different players the dopaminergic
terminals release dopamine within the
vicinity of these synapses which allows
the plasticity mechanisms to be induced
in response to activity and glutamate
release now we've studied those
plasticity mechanisms in mice using a
technique called two photon laser
scanning microscopy and patch clamp and
this involves basically taking brain
slices through the stratum of mice and
putting them on a microscope where we
can image cells and monitor their
electrical activity now directing an
indirect pathway neurons in this
preparation can be visualized in
distinct distinguished by using
transgenic mice in which direct or
indirect pathway neurons Express a
fluorescent protein that we can detect
optically so that in d2 back transgenic
mice if we take a slice of the stratum
indirect pathway neurons are green
whereas in d1 back transgenic mice
direct pathway neurons are green so we
can readily distinguish between these
two visually and it allows us to
selectively sample these two populations
of cells and our in our studies
so one question that we spend a lot of
time thinking about are what are the
rules governing the induction of
synaptic plasticity that we think
underlies the storage of information
about how previous actions have have
what sort of outcomes they have led to
and I'm not going to go into the details
of the intracellular signaling pathways
that underlies synaptic plasticity these
have been worked out for by a number of
groups over a long period of time
they're complicated and beyond the scope
of a talk like this one but what I can
tell you is that the rules are very
coherent and there's a fair amount of
consensus about exactly what the
determinants are from the standpoint of
the talk today though there are some
very simple rules that is in direct
pathway neurons these DSPs activation of
d1 receptors does two key things one is
it I told you it increases the
excitability that is from moment to
moment it increases the excitability of
direct pathway neurons and promotes any
ongoing action the other thing that it
does is it promotes long term
potentiation at glutamatergic synapses
and inhibits the depression of synapses
so d1 receptor stimulation will lead to
an overall strengthening of excitatory
synaptic input into direct pathway
neurons so both the short-term and
long-term effects of dopamine on these
cells that are mediated by d1 receptors
are in in concordance that is both will
tend to increase the activity in that go
pathway now in contrast in dopamine
acting to d2 receptors in indirect
pathway neurons does the opposite it
decreases the short-term excitability of
these cells and also promotes long-term
depression that is weakens the strength
of glutamatergic synapses which tend to
excite these cells and also at the same
time it will inhibit the induction of
long-term potentiation so it the overall
impact of d2 receptor
synaptic strength excitatory synaptic
strength is to decrease it so again both
short-term and long-term effects of
dopamine in these cells are concordant
that is they have the same net effect on
the activity of this particular group of
cells now we can study synaptic
plasticity using optical techniques
these are to the left here these are two
photon laser scanning microscopy images
of a spiny projection er you can see the
cell body and then dendrites here and
there's this little box over here shows
you like and again it's this box here
look at this box here this is blown up
over here to the right where you can see
these individual spines where synaptic
contacts are made what we can do is we
can monitor the strength of the synapses
of these places by uncaging glutamate to
mimic synaptic transmission now one of
the ways in which we can induce
long-term potentiation in these cells is
by simply depolarizing them a few times
to mimic strong synaptic input in
activity in the presence of molecules
that normally would be required to
induce long-term potentiation in a
particular brain derived neurotrophic
factor NMDA receptors and then depending
upon which cell type it is a gpcr
agonist so in direct pathway neurons we
activates d1 receptors and in indirect
pathway neurons we activate a HEA
adenosine receptor so the bottom line we
can monitor synaptic strength do this
induction and then go back and monitor
synaptic strength again afterwards to to
check on how whether or not synaptic
strength has been changed by this
induction protocol
and what we can see doing this these are
individual glutamate evoked responses
and you can see some spines some
synapses clearly potentiate whereas
others don't and so this was a little
bit of a surprise to us but I think it
tells us something very important in
particular it tells us that some
synapses are capable of undergoing
potentiation that is that he learned by
changes in dopamine receptor signaling
whereas others don't and I know this is
probably not politically correct but
I've labeled those that undergo changes
in strength with alterations in
dopaminergic signaling smart and those
that don't
Dom that is that dopamine unresponsive
so that we go from a situation like the
one on the upper left where the synapses
are roughly equal in strength we induce
global long term potentiation and and
some synapses will strengthen whereas
others will not okay now on average it's
about thirty to forty percent of the
access - synapses potentiate in this
sort of induction protocol all right so
that's kind of the backdrop of how
dopamine acts dopamine acts on direct
and indirect pathway neurons it controls
short-term excitability and it also
controls synaptic strength how is this
related to Parkinson's disease you know
that Parkinson's disease is the second
most common neurodegenerative disease in
the world the symptoms of Parkinson's
disease are well characterized rigidity
akinesia slowness of movement shuffling
of gait rigidity are all common symptoms
of Parkinson's disease sometimes a
static tremor is a is a symptom we know
that those core motor symptoms are
caused by the death of dopaminergic
neurons in the substantia [ __ ] pars
compacta
this just shows the healthy compacta
here at the top and the compacta of a
Parkinson's disease patient here
we're the dopaminergic neurons the
pigmented Brown neuro melanin containing
dopaminergic neurons have been lost okay
so yes what happens to the basal ganglia
circuitry in Parkinson's disease and I
know this diagram looks sort of
complicated and I apologize for that
I had a pointer I could be able to focus
your attention I'll try this is a
substantial Niagra right here okay now
this is the part of the brain again that
bi-directionally modulates these this
direct pathway the direct pathway here
and the indirect pathway here that we've
just talked about okay so what happens
to these these two pathways when the
dopaminergic neurons are lost well the
the prevailing view is that again the
direct pathway neurons which are here
they become hypo excitable alright and
so their activity diminishes whereas
indirect pathway neurons which promote
suppression of activity they become
hyper excitable so this leads to the
hypokinetic features of Parkinson's
disease okay but this view is based
solely upon that short term in
regulation of excitability that I talked
to you about it does not take into
account the changes in synaptic
plasticity or the role of dopamine yin
and controlling synaptic plasticity okay
it's why the fact this model is proved
to be a great heuristic value so again
this is I think is a very important
limitation of the existing model so one
of the things that we did was we set out
to understand exactly how that impacted
things the other thing that the model
does not account for is the the natural
tendency for neurons in the brain to
exhibit what's called homeostatic
plasticity that is if you perturb them
you make them either more or less
excitable for a sustained period of time
that it induces adaptations that tends
to restore the activity back to it is
set point this is a little bit like a
thermostat in your house the temperature
rises because it gets hot your air
conditioner comes on and it tends to
pull the temperature back down to
whatever your setpoint is about 65 or 70
degrees contrast or for example if it
gets cold your heater comes on so
neurons operate in much the same way
this has been work that's been described
in a number of key some key publications
by Gina Carano and Eve Marder and their
labs so one of the things that happens
is that intrinsic excitability of
neurons change that is they express a
different constellation of ion channels
that moves there their ability to spike
in one direction or another the other
thing that happens is that synaptic
strength also can scale in response to
perturbation so for example if you lower
the firing rate synaptic strength has a
tendency to get greater so that the
cells will begin to begin to spike at a
normal rate and conversely if you raise
firing rates what will happen is
synaptic strength will decline so these
two intrinsic and synaptic forms of
homeostatic plasticity are not accounted
for in the conventional models of
Parkinson's disease and I think it turns
out that there are important
determinants of what's going on all
right so let me sort of quickly go
through some of the evidence for this so
we've looked at mice again that have
been unilaterally allegiant this just
shows tyrosine hydroxylase immune or
activity on the left-hand screen and a
normal normal side and it's gone on the
lesion side so we mimic late-stage
parkinson's disease by killing the
dopaminergic neurons on one side of the
brain then we go and look at its finding
ions now we've interrogated individuals
synaptic connections using opto genetic
approaches basically what this involves
is expressing a light-sensitive channel
in a particular class of neurons and
then we can open those channels and
excite those axon terminals with a blue
laser and I just shown here over what we
can do is shine that blue laser along
individual spines and synapses which are
shown here and determine whether or not
there is a cortical synapse because we
limit the ops and expression to cortical
neurons by whether or not there's a
synaptically about response that is
whether transmitter is released and
excites the postsynaptic membrane so
doing this kind of thing what we found
was that in indirect pathway neurons
after you got rid of dopamine pretty
much what we had predicted to happen
what happen with dissin optic strength
happened that is what we know that
feature receptor signaling promotes long
term depression in inhibits long term
potentiation that is it tends to weaken
synaptic strength so if you get rid of
d2 receptor signaling what happens
synaptic strength grows it increases and
this is just shown here for on the left
hand side for individual synapses and
it's shown on the right hand side for
groups of synapses just shows the
distribution of EPS see amplitudes over
in large population now strangely though
in spite of the fact that synaptic
strength grew when you stimulated all of
the inputs from cortex into an
individual indirect pathway neuron the
aggregate synaptic strength did not
change well so you would think that this
would be the sum of all of the synaptic
inputs and so that should go up if the
individual strengths went out well what
happens is that when you do a dopamine
depleting lesion the the number of
synaptic contacts that cortex makes with
individual indirect pathway neurons
drops that's just shown here
the in controls the synaptic density is
fairly high and I just shown as a
summary here over to the right after
having done a lesion that synaptic
density drops both in proximal and
distal dendrite so this explains why the
aggregate synaptic strength didn't
change although individual synapses were
strengthened the number of synapses that
were being made dropped that is the
critical straddle connectivity was being
reshaped now what type of synapses were
pruned we know from again from a variety
of other studies including these that
it's primarily cortical synaptic or it's
commonly cortical synaptic connections
that are being pruned this just shows
again how we optically interrogate the
individual synapses and then determine
to determine which ones are cortical and
which ones are full Amick and the bottom
line here is that the proportion of
cortical synapses dropped in the
parkinsonian case in isp ends the other
thing that I think is particularly
intriguing that is still not fully
understood is that those synapses that
were pruned that were lost were dumb
ones that is synapses that did not
respond to dopamine and we we know that
because we can look at a proportion of
smart and dumb synapses along any one
stretch of dendrite in control and
parkinsonian conditions and and what
happened in the parkinsonian condition
is the proportion of smart synapses rose
so we know that the total number of
synapses xs- in emphasis is dropped so
the that means that the proportion of
the DH it's likely that what are we
being retained here are smart synapses
on average so that also suggests that
the origins that is the type of
information that's being conveyed at
smart and unsent synapses
is different and so the type of
information that indirect pathway
neurons retain in the parkinsonian state
is different than it is in controls I'm
gonna skip this slide and the bottom
line is this is a work of collaborators
Susan C sack and Gordon Arbuthnot the
bottom line here is that that the
synaptic pruning is true synaptic
pruning it's not just collapsing of the
spines into the dendrites and this was
shown by electron microscopy I'm not
gonna belabor that okay what about the
direct pathway neurons what about this
other population of straddled projection
neurons how do they change in the
parkinsonian State well just as we
predicted from the work on synaptic
plasticity normal animals again what d1
receptors do is they tend to promote
long term potentiation is in addition to
increasing the excitability of these
cells in the parkinsonian state the
strength of individual cortical steroid
synapses dropped and got weaker just as
as we would have predicted okay and in
contrast to the situation with is pans
when we look at the aggregate synaptic
response it dropped just as you predict
as the strength of individual synapses
drops the total number of synapses
stayed the same so the aggregate
response diminished so that direct
pathway neurons were less effectively
driven by cortical activity in the
parkinsonian State now you might have
expected that spine density would have
been altered in this case but it could
very well be that the spine density is
re to maximum in in spiny projection
neurons and couldn't rise any higher in
spite of the fact that these cells are
hypo excitable and so again from a
homeostatic mechanism standpoint you'd
think that they would they would grow
additional synapses so let me try and
summarize what I've tried to say so far
about homeostatic plasticity and what
happens outside of the classical model
of network adaptations in Parkinson's
disease following dopamine depletion in
indirect pathway neurons the
of d2 receptor signaling does two things
one is it increases the excitability of
indirect pathway neurons remember d2
receptor signaling is inhibitory it also
leads to synaptic potentiation because
d2 receptor signaling tends to promote
the depression or weakening of synaptic
strength so when you remove d2 receptor
signaling the opposite of those actions
occurs but but and so this is the basis
at least part in part the gain of
intrinsic excitability is the classical
model but this homeostatic plasticity
gets engaged to compensate for these two
adaptations
one is there's homeostatic synaptic
pruning which tends to counterbalance
the synaptic potentiation that is even
though some synapses get stronger you
get rid of a number of synapses about 30
to 40 percent and that tends to balance
total excitatory synaptic strength the
other thing that happens it doesn't that
I didn't show you is that there's
intrinsic homeostatic plasticity that is
is PM's become less excitable now at the
end of both of these homeostatic
adaptations which are tending to restore
indirect pathway neurons to normal
activity levels animals are still
symptomatic which means that there has
to be some uncompensated deviation with
extreme dopamine depletion now indirect
pathway neurons we see exactly the
opposite that is there's a loss of
intrinsic excitability there's synaptic
deep potentiation and depression that is
synaptic strength gets weaker alright
but again they're homeostatic
adaptations in this particular case it's
not synaptic as they're not synapses
added like their synaptic connections
removed in indirect path neurons
the major change seems to be in the
intrinsic excitability of direct pathway
neurons that become considerably more
excitable again which tends to minimize
the consequences of dopamine depletion
on global average activity
now again while this doesn't lead to
complete reversal of symptoms and with
extreme depletions that could help
explain why the threshold for dubbing
degeneration is so high in humans that
as these adaptations these homeostatic
adaptations may be successful with in
early stages of the disease so what we
know and as shown up here on the upper
right is that there's loss of dopamine
neurons over a long period of time well
before symptoms emerge and we think that
the loss of doubler chip neurons has to
achieve 50 or 60 percent before you see
any discernable symptoms and part of the
reason why that may be there are
definitely presynaptic mechanisms which
contribute to this this characteristic
of Parkinson's disease but postsynaptic
mechanisms the ones the homeostatic
mechanisms that I've described also may
help keep the system functioning
normally until it's simply overwhelmed
by the loss of dopaminergic neurons when
it becomes too great to compensate okay
now even though there are homeostatic
adaptations there are there are other
the other issues that I talked about
here which are the changes in synaptic
connectivity so that could have a very
profound influence on the functioning of
the strider that is the synaptic
structure synaptic input particularly to
is pians is changing in a way that will
alter their activity and the spatial
temporal pattern of activity and is
pians may be very critical to normal
movement control all right so let me
finish by talking about what happens
when we try and replace dopamine now
this is typically done by levodopa
treatment and levodopa is a precursor of
dopamine
it crosses the blood-brain barrier is
converted to dopamine by residual
dopaminergic neurons and probably
searched and urging neurons but what
this what levodopa does is it leads to a
spatio-temporal pattern of dopamine
concentration in the striatum which is
very unlike that that normally occurs in
Australia normally in the stratum there
is a basal level of dopamine and
dopamine Rises when dopaminergic neurons
burst fires but it rises for very short
periods of time in contrast would leave
an open treatment the dopamine
concentrations can rise and stay
elevated for a very prolonged period of
time and this prolonged elevation in
dopamine concentrations that constant at
doses which are sufficient to activate
d1 receptors leads to unwanted movements
like dyskinesia they also during the
period of time when dopamine
concentrations fall here unless this
during this period down here this is so
called off state this is one movement
becomes very very difficult so ideally
what you'd want is for dopamine
concentrations to be constant but they
don't they oscillate in this this way
between oral doses of levodopa so we set
out to understand the mechanisms
underlying that changes in this riedel
circuitry that might contribute to
dyskinesias in in this paradigm now
again I apologize about this slide this
just shows that we gave levodopa to mice
we induced dyskinesia by repeated dosing
of levodopa at a high concentration and
then we sacrifice the animals and looked
at their brains period during the off
state here ok
all right so what happens to synaptic
strength we leave it open treatment okay
in in ISBNs I told you that in the
parkinsonian state what happens as
synaptic strength Rises what levodopa
treatment does is it reverses that
increase in synaptic strength that's
exactly what we predict all right
dopamine come d2 receptor signaling
comeback induces Ltd normalizes synaptic
strength that's good but what was
surprising to us was that we knew again
we went back and look at the aggregate
synaptic response following levodopa it
was exactly the same as it was in the
parkinsonian state but we decreased
synaptic strength why was that well you
might guess it what happened was that in
with the administration of levodopa the
synaptic strength or the number of
synapses came back as this shown here so
levodopa treatment normalizes synaptic
strength that leads to re-establishment
of connections with indirect pathway
neurons this is in an adult brain and it
happens both in distal and proximal
synapses so levodopa induces rewiring of
the normal striatum now what types of
synapses were we restored again using
this out there genetic approach we've
been able to show that many of the
synapses that come back I'll leave it
open meant our cortical alright so
cortex is being rewired to these those
indirect pathway in following levodopa
treatment now there's there were several
of the people who had described similar
sorts of effects following levodopa
treatment so the results that I showed
you here have been corroborated by a
number of other groups so it's it's a
well-established consequence of levodopa
treatment what was particularly
interesting to us whose what came back
following levodopa treatment
the dumbs fines that is the spines that
were unresponsive to dopamine which
seems a little counterintuitive but
again I think these are the synaptic
connections that are being either added
or pruned by homeostatic mechanisms and
are not being affected by dopaminergic
signaling under normal circumstances now
which synaptic connections what type of
information is coming back to ayahs fans
we don't know at this point okay
so again what I've tried to show you
here is levodopa appears to restore I
ice pians via with new added dumb
synapses so again the sequence of events
here is that it is the addition of
levodopa entrances suppresses intrinsic
excitability leads to synaptic
depression all right which would make
the indirect pathway hypo excitable but
homeostatic mechanisms tend to reverse
these effects both homeostatic synaptic
our sprouting as well as changes an
intrinsic excitability which I didn't
show you which tend to normalize the
activity of indirect pathway neurons so
these are all good things the question
is whether or not this synaptic rewiring
yeah
leads to normal function or not and and
I think that that's that's an open
question that has to be pursued the
situation is not so simple indirect
pathway neurons that leads to abnormally
sustained d1 receptor stimulation again
rather than being stimulated for seconds
it's the d1 receptors are activated for
hours which leads to a whole host of
changes in the properties of direct
pathway neurons again this is just shown
this oscillation and straddle doping
concentration is shown here again this
is very this is non physiological
now again this leads to a whole host of
molecular adaptations and direct pathway
neurons the lots of pathway changes log
long lists of changes in gene expression
they're really profound changes in
direct pathway neurons in the dyskinetic
animals that were only beginning to
understand well one of the things that
has been and clearly implicated in the
dyskinesia that is the motor abnormality
associated with levodopa treatment is is
aberrant synaptic strength well that
thing that we've been studying here the
Italians have pushed this idea for some
time this is also captured in this
diagram which again shows here the
change in synaptic strength and
connectivity that we just talked about
but which is retained in this diagram
this is wrong this is restored but the
key thing is that the thought is that
changes in the strength of this synapse
from the cortex to direct pathway
neurons is thought to be aberrantly
potentiated through the mechanisms that
we've talked about okay so in the off
state we don't see this that is that
there's no aberrant potentiation of
direct pathway synapses that's retained
okay
there is a clear trace that perhaps
during the on stage there was a Burin
LTP however because there's a reduction
in spine density and you can see that by
looking at these diagrams and it's
summarized in in these plots where you
see that spine density changes it drops
following levodopa treatment and this is
true in both proximal and distal
dendrites and if you look carefully here
you can see a drop and in spine density
okay
well so if synaptic potentiation is a
problem is there some way that we can
mitigate it
without diminishing the therapeutic
benefit of levodopa we can't simply
block d1 receptors which are implicated
in this these are critical to triggering
adjust the dyskinesia but also they're
critical to changing the excitability of
direct pathway neurons in a way that
enables movement so it turns out that m4
muscarinic receptors are co-expressed by
direct pathway neurons that are
exclusive to direct pathway neurons and
they activate a signaling pathway which
inhibits adenyl cyclase and so should
mitigate d1 receptor signaling a
positive allosteric modulator which
simply potentiates endogenous m4
receptor signaling has been developed
that crosses the blood-brain barrier and
boosts m4 signaling we tested this in
synaptic plasticity protocols again I'm
going to go quickly through this the
bottom line is the aberrant synaptic
plasticity you see in these protocols
the aberrant long-term potentiation is
eliminated by an m4 muscarinic receptor
or positive positive allosteric
modulator another aspect of potential
synaptic strength which is aberrant in
this kinetic Hamill's is d potentiation
that is it's it's very difficult to
reverse an increase in synaptic strength
once it's happened the m4 pam enabled
that synaptic strengths to be reversed
but more importantly the m4 pam affected
behavior that is knowing something about
the synaptic mechanisms allowed us to
control behavior we've done this in two
models one is a mouse model and she's
just shown here it can also if I can use
this if you give levodopa or if you give
leave a dope at this point what it does
is it induces aberrant behaviors and
those are just shown here as a function
of time all right if you give the m4 pam
these aberrant behaviors are domen
they're not eliminated but they're
they're much weaker than they were
previously with the same levodopa dos
now this m4 pam did not impair the
ability of the animals to move it simply
diminished the unwanted aberrant
behaviors the dyskinetic behavior and
then to the right we have just a
statistical summaries but a mouse is not
a human so does the same thing happen in
primates the answer is yes again what we
can show here is that is that again we
give the levodopa here and the
dyskinesias are worse for some period of
time than the leave it up wears off if
we give the m4 pam these aberrant
movements are dramatically diminished
the diminished is as much as they are
with administration of amantadine which
is the only approved medication for
dyskinesias at this particular point in
time
so with optimization of the m4 Pam's we
think that we can alleviate dyskinesias
more effectively than with amantadine
and it's just the summary is shown on
the right hand side okay so let me let
me just summarize what I've tried to say
what I've tried to show you is that
dopamine does a couple of different
things to direct and indirect pathway
neurons in the striatum which is a part
of the brain that is involved in making
recommendations about movement and
action in particular environmental
circumstances the recommendations are
designed to optimize reward and minimize
punishment or pain all right so indirect
pathway neurons d1 receptors increase
the immediate excitability but they also
promote long term potentiation in
indirect pathway neurons as the pathway
that's responsible for suppressing
actions dopamine decreases excitability
and promotes long term depression at
glutamatergic synapses that is it
weakens them
now in Parkinson's disease the the loss
of dopamine leads to expected changes in
the intrinsic you giving immediate
excitability of directing indirect
pathway neurons it leads to an imbalance
indirect pathway becomes hyperactive
which leads to the symptoms of the
disease but there are also homeostatic
adaptations which tend to mitigate that
imbalance in direct and indirect pathway
activity and we think actually
compensate for partial loss of dopamine
that may occur in the early stages of
the disease and as a consequence may
limit symptoms but those homeostatic
adaptations come at a cost that is that
the circuit is rewired and so the
information that the advisers are using
to make the recommendations to cortex
are changing and we think that there's
diminished information is making it
harder and harder for both direct and
indirect pathway neurons to make
appropriate recommendations back to
cortex now would liebe dopa treatment
with sustained high levels this
oscillation in straddle dopamine that
occurs we think that there is partial
restoration of indirect pathway activity
but again it comes at a cost that is
that the homeostatic mechanisms which
are trying to keep indirect pathway
neuron activity within an acceptable
range lead to rewiring of the indirect
pathway and it leads to aberrant
strengthening of synaptic connections to
direct pathway now again one of the ways
in which that can be mitigated is by
constant more less fluctuations in
straddle dopamine concentration the
other way that it could be mitigated is
by during the on phase diminishing the
impact of d1 receptor stimulation on
direct pathway neurons and we think that
we can achieve that by an m4 positive m4
muscarinic receptor positive allosteric
modulator which seems to be very well
tolerated in animal models and doesn't
diminish the therapeutic benefit of
so at that point we've got a few minutes
I'll stop and acknowledge the people who
who did all this work first and then
we'll take any questions so much of the
work that I showed you was dead when I
Steve graves and Michelle day washing
Shan Josh Plotkin who are in my lab
tib-fib Luger was in my lab when he did
much of this work he's now and learned
Angela Chen see was responsible for all
of the dyskinesia work in rodents though
dyskinesia working in primates was done
in collaboration with aaron bazaar and
his colleagues at mo tack and the m4 pam
was developed by Jeff Kahn and some of
the work I didn't show you on signaling
involving RJ's proteins was a
collaboration with a new big Paul green
guard his longtime collaborator in the
characterization of synaptic
connectivity changes Jurgen West donated
m4 knockout mouse which helped us
localize and determine the exact Moloch
receptor subtype that was mediating the
dyskinesia Susan C second Gordon
Arbuthnot our longtime collaborators and
Miriam I'm in at MIT helped us pinpoint
some of the molecular changes that took
place in this keynesian of course none
of this work would impossible without
financial support from ni and yes the
JPB Foundation and the Michael J Fox
foundation and the ADP foundation so
thanks so I'm happy to you'll finish
that bar in a moment thank you so much
for that informative presentation so
before we get started on the question
and answer session I'd like to remind
our audience how to submit questions you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can so our first question is is it only
context and experiences or positive or
negative thoughts that influence whether
d1 receptors with d2 receptors are
stimulated okay so let me repeat that
question for you and it is is it only
context and experiences or positive or
negative thoughts that influence whether
d1 receptors or d2 receptors are
stimulated
all right so what I'm gonna try in here
okay let me see
dr. Samar we want to make sure that
everyone including the person who's
asking the question but we want to make
sure that all the whole audience is able
to share your answers and so I'll I'll
just ask you the questions verbally and
if you would just answer verbally don't
worry about typing an answer to an
individual person if you just answer
verbally that would be perfect so let me
if it's all right I'll we repeat that
question and if you just answer it for
everyone is it only context and
experiences or positive or negative
thoughts that influence whether d1
receptors or d2 receptors are stimulated
oh okay so let me let me go through the
questions okay
so one of the questions is is it only
context or experience or positive
negative thoughts that influence whether
d1 or d2 are stimulated so I guess some
other the question is really whether or
not direct indirect pathway neurons
control thought as well as movement may
be positive or negative thoughts can
influence the activity of dopaminergic
neurons and so I think that both d1 and
d2 receptors will be affected by
positive or negative thoughts so context
and experience only indirectly affect
the release of dopamine by dopaminergic
neurons which innervate the striatum I'm
not sure I completely answered your
question but I think both of those
pathways influence both movement and
thought and in the way that we we
described another question is is it true
that only 20% of the synapse is active
in producing spikes effects for LTP well
only 20 to 30% of the synapses were
potentiated in the protocol that we used
so I think and that percentage could
change it changed in the parkinsonian
State so the question is whether or not
the
synapses that I labeled um we're capable
of potentiating under other
circumstances and I think that that's
possible it's highly likely that the
proportion of synapses that we labeled
smart was an underestimate because there
are a lot of ways in which synapses
could not be potentiated in that in that
protocol so am i another question is
what is the effect size of homeostatic
plasticity and I think the question is
how big an effect compared to the others
is it really and quite frankly under the
conditions that we did our experiments
it was as big almost as the changes
produced by near-complete dopamine
depletion so my guess is that under
conditions of partial depletion which is
relevant to the early stages of
Parkinson's disease they may be of the
same size so I am convinced that the
homeostatic mechanisms are are
biologically very important to to
striatal function and I you know again
every other place that has been looked
at homeostatic plasticity turns out to
be extremely important in determining
the functional properties of neural
networks and so I think it's just been
it's not been appreciated same thing
happens in the basal ganglia is it
possible to modify d2 receptors in order
to promote activity rather than
depression could you restore function by
blocking d2 receptors so you can alter
the signaling linkages of d2 receptors
perhaps
but my question is what is the goal so
in the the changes in synaptic strength
that are media by d2 receptor signaling
are adaptive so you can think about it
this way under if if dummy levels rise
and d2 receptors get stimulated you you
want to make sure that the indirect
pathway does not suppress that action in
the future I guess it wasn't very clear
about this so the best way to do that is
to make sure that whatever contextual
information let's say the contextual
information is a is Ben and Jerry sign
that next time you see a Ben & Jerry
sign that that sensory input does not
activate indirect pathway neurons which
would keep you from walking in the door
what you want to do is you you want to
walk in the door and so the best way of
doing that is to make sure that the
connections to indirect pathway are weak
and so that's what the d2 receptors do
is the number our quality of spines
critical in Parkinson's yes I think it
absolutely is because this is the only
way in which information is passed from
cortex and thalamus to spiny projection
neurons and so I think they're
absolutely critical these are the
primary synaptic contacts of spiny
projection neurons okay we have a bunch
of other questions here let me let me
pick one since we're out of time how to
enhance smart synapses and therapy
strategies for Parkinson's disease
patients that's a great thing you always
want to promote in enhance smart
synapses I am I think the that it's as
in society it's the balance between it's
the yin and the yang of
of this that is important to normal
function here's one way of thinking
about the smart and dumb sentences you
want some inputs some information not to
be affected by the outcome of an action
i if you're an advisor you want to get
objective information about context that
really is independent of whether or not
in that context you in the past you did
something that that worked or didn't
work so I think that there's some
there's an important role for synapses
that are not responsive to dopamine in
the straddle circuitry and so the bottom
line here is I don't think that we need
to know more about smart and dumb
synapses but I think that there's some
reason to keep synapses that are
unresponsive to dopamine in place
all right well again I want to thank
everyone who tuned in this was a real
experience for me I apologize
that it was a little bit clunky I I hope
that it was of some value and and my
email address was on the first slide if
you have any questions please don't
hesitate to email me I'd be happy to
answer any other questions that I didn't
get to in this question and answer
period thank you
I would like to once again thank dr. Sir
Meyer for his presentation today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through September 2016 you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward that
announcements your colleagues who may
miss today's live event see you next
time goodbye